and I think yes we are live welcome to
the iron Lords podcast in the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 123 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got gears 5 early previews
astral train impressions telltale
Studios revival Sony acquiring remedy
and control to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
who is not only one of the most
passionate personalities in gaming but
is easily one of the top 5 podcast songs
in the game oh man whether it be as
candid hot takes on the gaming industry
oh it's witty one-liners this
charismatic Lord is always willing to
engage in respectful debate regarding
the common bond that unites us all
introducing the creating host of the
crossfire podcast panelists of xbox
nation and co-host of mooch and crap in
the mornings fellow destiny fan fellow
Avengers fair and the Lord who reminds
us all that gaming the stodgy could be a
hell of a drug laughs from New York
State if making his return into the
realm of the Lord's my main Lord mooch
how you doing sir
then I've got to be honest with you I'm
gonna hope you don't mind I'm gonna take
that whole snippet right there that is
gonna be my intro for every video I do
going forward that is absolutely the
best man thank you so much I'm being
here on the show with you guys is an
honor and I mean that wholeheartedly you
don't understand you guys do something
that nobody does and that is you grab
people from all consoles all years all
generations bring people to the
forefront to have a logical open
discussion about sometimes hot topics
sometimes just gaming reviews and you
know it doesn't matter what it is I
gotta be honest with you I feel
extremely comfortable here and I want to
thank every single
the Lord's for having me today much
appreciated much appreciated moosh man
you know how it is when we get together
we've talked about it for a long time so
and good to have you back last time we
had you it was outstanding
just have a fun man bring all that good
stuff man what you been playing man well
I'll tell you the truth so we are
playing a lot of control right now and
so I think the audience the audience is
gonna love to hear this it's good I had
a choice and listen I did you know
listen you don't get to name much for
nothing okay so I've been reaching out
to 505 games for I'm not a I'm not
kidding you we're just about 60 days 60
days I mean like I need a code for this
I know you you don't give them the
channels my size listen let's look past
that let's just get through this just
give me a code I'll make it up to you so
nonetheless I finally get the code and
they're like listen you you can have a
code no problem but tell us the console
of choice and you guys know okay you
guys know I'm gonna go green first I
always go to so I did my homework I'm
looking at everything and I see that
control gets a mission or two and I
don't care about the clothing exclusive
I said listen for the due diligence to
the channel and the people listening I
said when I do the review let me get the
PlayStation version for once and let me
try it out now
I will say the game itself is phenomenal
I'm enjoying it I I'm gonna go ahead and
I want to hear what you guys have to say
to counter this but I do I gotta be
honest with you though I think this may
be the game that people will remember
remedy for as we move forward I do
I think it'll overlap no remember remedy
may be enough for good yes yeah cuz you
know dizzy definitely goes on me once a
week
I'm dizzy I hope you feelin better you
know dizzy super chat $2.00 give up the
knees you might be honest um you know
but what i'ma tell you is you see that
statue in the back you see what doing
was asking you you're asking you to put
your knees in the back
right over well what just means in the
box is looking clean brother went anyway
move so just been a hundred percent
control it's been a lot of control to be
honest with you because I mean I wanted
to do the due diligence to get out get
that actually that review out for
everybody before listen you get a review
out three four weeks after it comes out
who we kiddin right but at the same time
I've said let me do that but I will say
that I'm also trying to sneak in a
little bit that man of Madden right and
that's the I'm gonna go ahead and say
the successor to until dawn right so now
we could beat that the night before
lives I'll tell you I'm only about two
and a half hours into it listen I say
it's all time mooks long a boiler over
30 40 minutes you'd be done that's it
okay no he's not wrong I can tell this
is gonna wrap up quick but I mean at the
same time I gotta say a lot of people on
xbox didn't get to experience it because
they didn't have you know they never ps4
to play until dawn so far and I'm sure
addict can agree to this if he's saying
what I think he's saying I think until
Dawn's gonna Trump man um at the end of
a day hold on a second what you got to
pay the bills shadrach age man
thank you brother with the trap he ages
he just said I know well you know he
okay he hits me on Twitter all the time
so he was giving me a big shout-out for
the garden for a doom statue that's on
Kos this up right now and you know he
had a lot of comments that was inside
and I do appreciate every week that he's
looking forward to that right there and
I do appreciate all this good positive
comments that's on Twitter Cedric H is a
real dude so anybody that's in the chat
right now definitely you know follow him
because he's definitely a good positive
brother thank you have the same pose
when I get up from bed
how you gonna tear up the world
screaming a building I see you monkey
punching everything what's going on des
but yeah
so you know we have the we don't have
Forsman so it's there we're horsemen
down there salute the loss aw man the
sorry Thomas could not make it man work
has him under the rope
but holy next week he shall return I
ain't Bank shall return we also got some
giveaways next week
so stay tuned for that and saw don't
work too hard man we mission but of
course we still got the other three
horsemen of gaming my coals for the cold
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game Kagura Lord of reviews of
the young mommy I think he just calls me
water revenues because he keeps want he
wants me to keep doing this I want you
to keep going I do appreciate you when
you do your review sir actually you help
form my opinion on you know getting a
game thank you sir do appreciate it keep
working get back to work
yeah it's been a it's been a week this
resort games have really picked up more
this week than they have been the whole
year I'm going to what I was cleaning
you only play stuff this on day past now
what Microsoft should do for me is the
costume with a cape this is Captain game
past your walls and I'm a yell out
getting gas oh yeah I'm not I am not
emitting to playing control that's my
happening here I've been playing control
I've been playing that not until dawn
yeah well see the thing about that game
is its short but you the decisions you
can make makes it longer Oh
like for instance me kid where there's
like these little mini games you have to
play to keep to like for instance when
you're trying to keep quiet you have to
press a on their heart
okay kid sucks that that completely
sucks at that if you look at the stream
kid literally is is is getting himself
killed over and over again and he was
running from you know I was like kid
it's me
the the it's me stop running he just
kept running and he fell down an
elevator shaft and got that dude killed
so you know oh I've been uh I've been
destroying the whole press start this
cord and you you heard about you Yukio
bro not her what you did to some people
on a swim or some other podcast Court
supposed I hope II would you know we
there but they're currently their best
member in discord Kofi's trying to get
me you know too humble in the one on the
switch no but it's on Steam the reason
why I'm saying that because I'm a friend
of mine uh I got it I got to watch the
podcast you know he's overnight guy and
he wanted some content to watch to keep
pass through the night I was like you
know very humbly I'm like well you see
the shirt that I'm wearing right um go
to that site and um watch the podcast so
he watched it he was like um when I came
to he was like yo how come you need to
talk about you yo what are you talking
about he said cuz he has to switching in
hand all the time I said Cognito love
you okay I can't justify its $40 on ya
no no don't-don't-don't pick that up he
said is $40 of super crap when they drop
the ball you know what it is on Steam
Xbox on PlayStation 20 but for some
reason because they've done an update on
the switch that they're probably gonna
update the rest of the games they want
to charge 40 oh no you know wise to UM
$40 that it is because they charging you
by the joy con the to account okay you
know what you might be on something you
hold on deaf deaf singer say a shout to
you he said Oh subhanAllah pocket attic
what deck is you are you using for you
yo that's not like a job that made
nobody talked about no he just wants to
know what I beat them with Romeo can
beat me with whatever you have sound
like he will decibel I don't know what
he said because oh it's like literally I
told them I didn't I didn't talk smack
or anything I just walked it their cope
it was like you got to play my mans
first cuz I'm playing someone else a lot
right like oh but Kofi no no no you
gotta tell me just totally so I played
his man's Molosser he had you fight the
sub first you gotta [ __ ] my bodyguard
first suddenly Kofi I beat him and then
BG wrote it
BG I guess BG thought I was like the new
person on the block
I never played this usually try to get
that quick out there quick dummy okay
and then I smoked his like you should
have here bheegi bheegi was like he
doing witchcraft a pedigreed Oh what you
used to do for these you do yeah I play
yo-yo competitively for about 10 years
oh yeah yeah I travel I travel miles
like three or four states over I've been
to Nationals twice but it is a big
Kofi's alright man
I think I'm gonna play literally two
turds it he's like yeah
addy go stomp me first if you go to his
last stream the one before the one that
was two days ago I played my first two
cards he's like I don't even know what
he's doing he's gonna beat me I know
he's gonna beat me way to have
confidence Kofi
the whole time I play coffee BG's like
man like this cart should be paying we
gotta stop the podcast
undead out here talking slander right
now shoutout to a multiverse and of the
game in perspective he's saying when I
Opie go stop ducking multiversal Oh see
we know you to ring undead the rest of
them we
pick off multi work in one day love it
all right
okay so okay let me tell you something
their comment on something that doesn't
exist it's not oh this is a fact but
what you what you're not gonna do what
you're not gonna do this do you think
you just heard addict tell you what he
dude is smoking right you told him right
you have never heard nobody on IOP talk
about they taking losses and put knees
in boxes yes I want you to really think
about your challenge that you're putting
out here you may be confident in your
ability but see this is what's gonna
happen no peace fire is gonna rain down
your head left out there without you
and we've no gun for your team one by
one and put them in a box
everybody's a champion if I got four
days worth the time on that game oh no
like like like dizzy says both offers
been ducking into destiny competitive
fake so weak they don't wonder yeah we
got to our room to listen nothing in
that [ __ ] well I wouldn't see it anyway
because it's not color but I am boots
podcast was I love it we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka
the excess gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than their premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement hmm beloved like a guy
you exhibit we're doing fantastic today
and you know come yo all right shut off
everybody that watched boxing yesterday
and so um one of the pound-for-pound
best fighters out there a moment chanko
the city on the chinko fight Lou
Campbell yesterday that's two Olympic
fighting for belt and um what did Loma
chenko do this time mama tracker winning
and do exactly what he normally do beat
the brakes off the opponent
it wasn't worthy to put up a combat talk
for because I know he was not danced on
him all night when a decision and that's
exactly what he did
so what I want to do is talk about what
I was playing this week gamepad saucy
booming everybody going crazy on my
timeline
talking about all the blue the blue
which blue which I'm like all right
that's what I'm talking about so when I
said yeah we don't need remedy we don't
need I don't mean no control because I
got my blue which is moving up Nolan I'm
like okay let's get ready so you wanna
call you talking in the girl and is like
yeah yeah and then you get to the site
now lead him up to it they telling you
that your boy got some mental issues
something going on with this dude you
intrigued by the story so far when I got
actually a chance to control the game
this my interest fell to the floor let
me tell you something this is reason why
I was $29 and I'm gonna call a spade
alright I like my games to be fluid on
my xbox one X I did not pay five hundred
dollars that have stuttering frame rate
on a high powered resolution it's
running man I don't know what it's doing
but boy if that game don't look bad
you're walking you're not running so was
not smooth maybe somewhere else is a
patch they gotta give me a patch give me
a passenger smooth let me can I ask you
a question yes sir because this is in
you being the king of okay game pass
this is this is where the question lies
with you oh right
here's my only issue with it this
happens more often than not where we
have a situation right now
we're game pass is kind of like the
arcade and you guys gotta ride with me
for a second on this cuz you guys know
that we all grew up in the same era we
know this situation better than most
right in the arcade you remember being
young we were out there they had two or
three of these platform games out there
okay back in a day you wanna go as far
as Mortal Kombat these are the big games
out there he said okay they had that
they had the bangers people calling now
the bangers right mmm and then in the
back way in the back they had right they
had a bunch of games it some would be
like yo King okay here's a couple
quarters go ahead and jam out that you
make no I tried that I'm done with that
I'm not playing that game right wait
yeah that's why it's in the back right
yeah okay
so my point being is that like I feel
like game past definitely has his
bangers right there's no way around it
it definitely got your money's worth
there's nobody that can argue that game
pass is not the best value out in gaming
right now you can't argue it you cannot
argue that you keep with 200 games for
99 cents and then tell me it's not a
good value you can't for the problem is
though a lot of times we're clicking on
these games and we're having the
experience you just had when it's not
one of the five to ten bangers with what
you're having with Blair Witch and don't
you feel like that's kind of where I
myself personally say these people are
going I don't care it's okay Blair Witch
was a stuttering mess but guess what it
was a game pants I paid ninety nine
cents on a pair right we got to stop we
got to stop using game pass as a crutch
because I respect that opinion and I'm
always under fence of debt what about
when you say they release Devil May Cry
5 and they're so and and what about when
they released all the other 20 Bang is
bangers like you called them in there
and then they put this game the only
reason why I'm calling this game in
particular album because Microsoft
solace or fit to put this on the screen
at e3 like this was a banger you
understand so everybody in that game
past timeline is a banger I'm going in
it's not a banger bruh I don't care what
it is I mean my brother Oh Lord Angele
family said the story is great and he's
into the story and he can overlook
certain things
I am a graphics [ __ ] Oh Nene going in
my expectations is here especially when
you put them here any showing that
Summer Jam screen we clean when it come
to me where can i buy one I just put the
link in the description brother get over
there to that teespring store so we got
that and then my boy Philly Eagle
podcast Wars huh that's not but if we
must I'm voted with my wallet did I only
use the greatest everyone else second
place there's a loot Lawrence but boy
Philly ego and of course brat basement
radio arcade podcast Henrique come on
guys don't complain it's one game pass
it's one dollar Oh wrap the captain of
the flip-flop I hope you got your
flippers on the day yes I'm going at you
breath my man my brother listen it's
just this like you said we got those
bangers we got those guys that game was
set setting me up to believe there was
something that it was not right but then
I also realized while I was watching it
Wallace said lion gates games
distributor of the situation okay no
it's not because I was thinking that
this everybody come on don't front guys
y'all leading up to it was like yeah
this is the reason why we didn't buy
Alan Wake and this reason why I control
his multi play and this is the reason
why no this is the reason why I'm upset
because was supposed to be something
about at least lake is smooth when I'm
walking just be smooth please Manning is
not I'm sorry but other games that I do
play in there like de Rouen ER like neo
chrome well you know those games are in
the back but those games deserve to be
on that screen and we aren't on that
screen and that's my only complaint you
put this game up there like this is the
next thing that we should look out for
right before we get cares which is a
banger but this isn't you know and I was
just really mad at it everybody's
bloviating is supposed to be hot and
it's not
again right the wrapping we give it to
our super check my flip-flop game is
strong and of course we got myself the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
this [ __ ] no beat Lord kognito spreading
that realness to the realm of the ILP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so for me is
literally just being on a shoe chain as
you i've seen i've been getting that and
we'll talk about that later
um dragon quest 11 demo on a switch I
played that really cool got a chance to
see all extra features whatever they
give you about 10 hours to rock was
pretty fun and then um NBA 2k demo with
the monetization track no no I saw you
when I was in your timeline when you put
that up you should know that you should
have not came to the show with that
right there no we're not gonna do that
today even everybody on your time I told
you that was a bad idea to really listen
[Laughter]
bro I mean I'm in the bathroom I'm at
the DMV mooch of although I'm planning a
plan to cages like you ladies should not
be called 2 K so we call to G oh you
playing the 2d version another $2 super
Chester thank you for showing color does
the switch have the best exclusives now
right rockin that and oh destiny of
course man just finishing things up
before shadow keep the tip diamond no
doubt to me this was substituted iron
law panel
salut to you brother that's what's up
and um yeah I suppose get right into it
man we got into what the Lord's are
playing and Lord mooch has already been
given D for your treatment before you
can say IOP please check that out y'all
yes men this video game system is three
levels of mooching were explained
absolutely I should put that in print
and sold it bro 50 levels of mucho no
that's that New York built in trust me
do you know but real quick all right I
just want to ask you before we get into
it um I know last time we do the thing
that we always do which is the top 5 and
you had a strong fire last time yeah
legend is older yeah Castlevania talked
about yes we are souls and Resident Evil
were your five franchises so my question
now has anything change is anything you
want to move in move out or does it
remain the same of yo 5 listen to what
we just said I like that you brought
that up and thank you for doing the
homework on that cagney know because
here's the thing to be honest with you
so Zelda right we're still talking about
Link's Awakening coming out that's gonna
be great ok either you love it or not
that's gonna hit you in the nostalgia so
that's good you and whether even if you
say to me today you're not gonna buy it
I guarantee you you're 40 to 50 dollars
short when that comes out right so then
we said Castlevania and we all played
blood-stained ritual tonight okay
fantastic game can't say it didn't give
you Castlevania vibes unbelievable gears
listen gears v is in fact what we wanted
it to be and we saw that Friday right we
need anything great we saw up Friday but
we'll take Friday mmm so we got that
right and then I believe will hit me
with those last two real quick Cognito
come do this on the fly the other two
Dark Souls Dark Souls Rock yup and
Resident Evil that's all yes Resident
Evil right now has a brand new game on
the horizon Resident Evil 8 with it
there say that's gonna be kind of like a
telltale meets Resident Evil biohazard
right super-combined I'm okay with that
they continue to take that franchise and
move it forward okay this is what I'm
saying so Mike or five that I said it's
not specific to one game
in that genre one game in that series it
goes games branch out to so many of the
games we all love and hold dear right
now so I can't change those five I can't
because that's that's that's our moral
upbringing right those know brought up
that way no I gotta take it from there
and move forward with it so we can
branch off for those five and we're
gonna do that today okay but no I can't
change any of those
okay now fair Delfi I just want to make
sure cuz I can say with the rice because
I know sometimes we bring people back
and people like you know what I forgot
such as such or I forgot this and I'm
violent boot you staining on it like I
gotta defend that far because those are
in ok bro you gave me that list you said
listen these are the things I want you
to come on - it was ILP 76 yes sir you
say come on here and you know you always
gonna be prepared for your show right
you come on there check out that was
something that I put some time and
thought into and I think even now I
wanna I actually think it would be more
fun for me to say you know what no I
like to switch out this for that yeah
but to be honestly the reason I won't is
because even though those five may not
hit home for everybody listening or even
maybe resound for me today right it goes
live right yeah they breach the breach
out to the games that I'm loving today
because of that as my core so that's
where I'm kind of coming from with those
salute salute the Meuse man strong 5 we
love it last week's poll results are in
the people have spoken to the question
with the gamescom announcements of
microsoft initially stating they have no
plans releasing first party titles on
other consoles without later stating
that they'd like to see game pass on all
platforms which statement do you believe
is closer to the truth the winner of a
runaway three outweigh ILP poll at
sixty-one percent is the stop
fear-mongering Xbox first party games
will remain on Xbox second place at 20
SEC to visit was the petty Lords I don't
care
PC master-race will have them all group
the last place of the close 17 percent
was the Xbox first party will eventually
be on all platforms open your eyes group
shout to all the lords who participated
in this poll law
mooch yes about this man the Xbox
faithful say you know people
fear-mongering these games got the
exclusive with this man they said this
is a tough call because I like how you
started the segment Cognito to be honest
with you and the fact that we've got two
points of Xbox brass telling us to go
left and one telling you to go right
right and it all comes out within hours
of each other it's not days at the
moment and and this is confusing and
this is why I think all of us being the
Xbox fans that we are you scratch your
head and you we all don't know we
honestly have no idea and where I lean
right now myself personally you have to
look at the the model that they're
building it doesn't matter what I truly
feel you have to look at what they're
building what they're building is an
infrastructure I think when Phil went to
have that meeting years and years and
years ago back beyond be even 2045 2013
2014 before Phil took over Satya said
something to the extent of you will have
to put these services and use our
services if you want that Xbox you want
that Microsoft money ok
and I think Phil said I can do that I
can save this brand but like Phil said
promise me that when I do do this root
that you're fully behind me you know
because it's like being so Bank
important statement you said it is yes
it is so that's why I'm defending Phil
there ok because Phil went to battle to
keep Xbox alive now we can't get up so
we have to look at it this way there's
no way there's no way that they're gonna
keep exclusives to just the console my
idea I mean that's the model that they
put out that's not my opinion right look
at what they're doing there's rumors you
don't have to listen to the I guess
something on Colin Moriarty he said he
had heard something or something like
that that they shopped halo Master Chief
collection to go on PlayStation let's
take that right out of the equation
right but they've got an instance right
now where these tweets in these mentions
that you're talking about Cognito days
before any of them were breached or even
discussed we found that that Orion apply
force is going this week mm-hmm okay so
let's stop this nonsense
the fact of the matter is Xbox is going
to become I don't want to use just the
word an app but game pass is going to be
everywhere and if game passes everywhere
we already know they said this it's now
part of their doctrine that with Xbox
game pass comes first party games so it
may not go to PlayStation but you can
bet it's going to be on everything else
and so that's why I can't I didn't I
don't remember which executive it was I
think it was Aaron green I'm doing the
competish oh yeah he said yeah right
so whichever one said that they will
stay exclusive I think that person
probably got a phone call from Phil
about four seconds after that tweet was
live it was like
weren't you at last Thursday's free
bagel meeting when I had everything set
up I told you we're going all over the
place why'd you tweet that out oh I'm
sorry about that I'm over you know I'm
over here checking something out taking
pictures of these new sneakers I got I
got confused and I tweeted it out I
didn't mean it that's the conversation
Aaron and Phil had I just reenact it for
everybody live okay I'm just saying like
I think it's gonna be everywhere and I
think that's their model and if that's
what they're going with there's nothing
wrong with that but let's let's be clear
let's be concise and let's let the
consumer know what the direction of Xbox
is that's all I am consumer doesn't know
exactly what ever to consume the ones
the consumer has to be guided to that
point because if you allow the consumer
to run your company you because your
company is gonna run itself to the
ground so we all know I mean common
sense wise let's all look at it guys I
mean to be honest with you all this fear
monger and stuff that these people are
doing is definitely ridiculous and we
have to get it together you know if you
have a Playstation and you don't want
like game paths on your system don't
download the app if you have a you know
a switch and you don't like game passing
system don't download the app if you
have an Xbox and you have game paths
don't subscribe for it you know this is
a situation where it's up to you they
give you total control you can game and
play wherever the hell you want to play
so I've never heard a situation where
they say a mixed message into a
situation or it's not mixed messaging
I'm gonna tell you right now time meet
and didn't go like how he said the free
bagel messaging in the meat and the meat
was only like five minutes and Phil came
on said world domination
listen Phil Dominus Maximus Splinter
definitely the situation you know he
didn't get that title yet we're not
gonna give him that title yet until
after he conquers next generation and
I'm gonna tell you right now he's gonna
conquer next generation the reason why
he's not he's not a con connects
generation because this is a different
feel you saw
that landed down the patinka with a
knife and he gained him out the gunfight
winning and got that chicken dinner
so right now you give him Phil he's
landing with all equipment that he
already means he's going and he's
prepared for war he got the money he got
this people and he got the messaging
going forward if you think the messaging
is mixed up you are not seeing clearly
really the messaging is world domination
huge now see I like listen I gotta be
honest with you right now I'd like to
put King in charge of Xbox listen
everyone says that because here's the
thing what King is preaching is facts
and I can get you can stand behind that
and follow that leader right to the end
the only problem I have is you had a
remember King kognito read you to direct
tweets from two main soldiers right
underneath those dudes right now is
looking at the wall with the dunce cap
on check them out the corner which are
typical mix messaging from Microsoft
however the road map is there Xbox to be
an X like of service with Xbox or
multiple platforms so what do you say to
that cake baby no that's exactly what's
gonna happen
um there's nothing wrong with it guys no
listen if play down the place they
should learn to get down right our
services on our infrastructure on this
situation is really bad let's go with
our competitor right and get this
service that they can offer us
that's the Trojan horse baby do you
understand what happened when they let
the Trojan horse into the yes when we
let it into Troy and they closed the
gates cuz the gates was impenetrable
film it Phil went to Sony company and he
put a Serb outside I said yeah it's a
servo they left the server out there for
three days
maybe we cuz we do need services so
let's bring service in so when they got
there and night they popped out with
contracts listen man you do not let your
competitor control the mic switch
because you can walk to your mic and
turn it off
Troy fire that's my dude he knows for a
fact when their game passes on your
Playstation 5 are you playing whatever
gears or whatever you doing you know who
smiling more than you you know who Phil
you know why because he's gonna have
that shirt on that we bout to put out
who did that for you we see that king
they're making money and you're talking
about making money are we talking about
being an industry leader in the games
world right and there's two separate
things as far as mind share so you're
right everything you just said I'm kind
of I'm backing you up on except for the
fact you said you want to have him
control in the light switches I Got News
for you we all talk [ __ ] about the power
companies we all play pay every month
right but in the end of the day as long
as you keep paying them they don't shut
off the switch well you're never
shutting that switch off trust me
the money's coming in exactly the same
long as they pay like they wait we don't
buy it we continue to do but the day
they slip up this what happened we got a
lot of show to get into bad so bonus
topic you know saying I have a little
bonus Tom dere's five men early
impressions have been out on what a
shout out a boy just Gordon for Windows
Central outstanding previews right now I
know much you talked about it on
crossfire yes sir and um yeah man I just
wanna bring this to them
right now obviously this is a hot-button
topic you know we're hearing positive
reviews of gears 5 and you know very
impressive so I guess my question for
the lords is like now that this is
coming out and we all know how a lot of
us felt you know I'm saying about the
marketing approach with the campaign
you know it's far especially in regards
to e3 as opposed to now coming out with
game come on you know was it the correct
approach you know I'm saying so I want
to start off with mooch I know this was
a sizzling move eight
oh yes buying a shout out the moves out
of this Lucca crap everybody Brad was in
there I just dog cradle it was a fire
show first let's make that stupid sure
cuz you bothered tear into the bridge of
Lords beat the rug have a great show
much love you already know salute but oh
yes I'm dizzy
yeah when what is even better when you
guys think they'll get game passed and
be able to play online without paying
for game fast Xbox Live smart tactics
hash tag PSN is trend oh my god busy
dizzy
I believe some like that I really do
because especially when you roll game
pass and all that up and together they
actually paying to play with other
people say I think the holdup is
honestly the fact that PlayStation
really doesn't want to play nicer people
right now and do the cross play but I
think that's the only hold up we're
getting that game pass on but once that
hurdle is passed
once they already fall back real fast
inside the next generation they're gonna
sign the paperwork
you understand you got to put the boot
on the neck of a forty able to sign so I
think the move will be on the neck quick
no doubt but back to mooch man like I
said Mendes cross Fighters Friday so
let's get back into it man like what's
your feeling with this whole Kia's 5
situation about so let's let's talk
about the essence of where the where the
discussion kind of comes into play right
now we all saw just the past couple days
we saw another trailer for the movie
Joker right mm-hmm and everybody's like
oh that's fire I can't wait a guy I
already bought tickets it's not coming
out for them so the good was it comes
out in October I heard or whatever it
comes out a minute from now but if you
go back two months ago we also saw a
clip of Joker and we've had time to
about it we've had time to discuss it
get height right I don't need to see
another origins clip of Joker I know
that Joker had a hard upbringing people
ridiculed him he was slapped he was
taken he was stripped and deprived of
all of his like merits right until he
became the evil sinister Joker we know
this why do we need to show two trailers
let me tell everybody on the iron Lords
part yes why to bring up hype to get
people talking to bring excitement back
and my whole point right now with gear
isn't that which is it that what people
wanted though they capture hooray wanted
they want to content they wanted to see
trailers to get hype to play this game
really but we saw it Friday we didn't
see it at e3 when they have NBC ABC CBS
every single media outlet with cameras
on nope we get a mode in gate and
multiplayer then you have Gamescom not
necessarily the same media press 350,000
foot traffic gamers we don't see
anything they flew rod all the way out
to Germany we got some CGI no way we
could've done listen we could have done
that in a tweet from his studio in
Seattle so here's my point right or
Vancouver yeah I got it you'll be coming
all you want unless you're paying you go
to the movies and when the coming
attractions comes you go stand in the
hall and you don't want to see them and
you don't have much of an argument
because we want to see what we're going
to buy and so that was my main thing all
I'm saying is that these these these
snippets we saw in the preview and again
shelter Jeff Gordon who did an
unbelievable job that was jqr no
substance everybody take a second after
the show and tweet jazz and say thank
you you're the reason I'm buying this
like because that man did the marketing
so what I truly feel is that we should
see that and this is the concerning
factor this doesn't just end it gears
five because now that everybody saw the
gears five preview now it's easy to go
oh
see I told you to worry about it now
you can't say that before it comes out I
was saying it way before then right you
know I'm saying you gotta have that you
gotta have but my thing is is my concern
is this so now we've we've had this
discussion gears five looks fire
I can't wait to play it I'll be there at
9 p.m. on the 5th like everybody on this
panel no doubt but at the same time are
you guys worried like I am that we're
not gonna see now we're not gonna see
halo infinite till three and a half days
before it drops like we need to see
these games because listen but I don't
care if we're talking about movie
trailers I don't care what we're talking
about we always want to see the product
before we make the purchase listen
before Sonic you know that burger chain
before they came up to New York that was
a southern chain okay before they came
up to New York three months of
commercials about a hamburger I know
what a hamburger I don't need anything
about that why don't have to get hype
you know what they wanted me to go try
it when they said open now they got us
hype for a hamburger okay I've eaten
50,000 hamburgers but this is why you do
your promotions in your marketing
correctly you can't just say the
hardcores impress on Friday no motion
let me ask you a question did you apply
for market and direct the reason why and
first know what addict do you thing
because I'm gonna give y'all why I got
what you got why you got it and why
y'all was complaining for no reason at
the end of the day should they have
showed this at e3 of course right but
did they not show trailer at Gamescom
like you're acting like it's three days
before it came out we didn't see nothing
they showed something at Gamescom right
they show that they show the opening
night of games calling anybody Devery
the role ition couldn't put together a
CGI I know you guys want a trailer but
when you get a trend that we want to see
more see I don't want a pamphlet
gameplay they said this is gonna be the
biggest most diverse different gears
well show me that don't show me that
when would have been an acceptable time
to see this besides three just because
it's the biggest stage in gaming history
they used it as a strategic thing guess
where they're getting stomped where
they're getting stomped across seas
guess with a knockin song in Norman's a
matter
you're shooting it down then they show
either James Caan I saw more CGI with a
five-second blip of over shoulder III
everyone has been talking about kids 5
we could continue a today they would get
boots back now this is just a witch hunt
man yeah you people are never happy
depending on what's going on you know
they they show you what you want and
Gamescom people said for weeks at a time
we said it's on we want to see more on
the story we want to see more on the
story they let alright man calm down
don't shoot us will show you more we
show you more gangster we want to see
more gameplay you can't keep these
people happy
wait a minute I'd love to use the food
and analogy real quick again so sonic
said we say listen says I feel great
listen I got news for you so late I'm
gonna see those burgers I'm gonna skills
burgers I gotta show you some burgers
and then they show us those fresh-cut
fries listen that's not the same thing
right okay we wanted to see you're gonna
tell me to go get those fries and it
look like advertising right just walk
away I'm gonna have a good picture of
the man you listen real quick though so
attic you're gonna tell me this so real
quick and I respect everything you're
saying I know where you're coming from I
really do but if you're gonna be the
coalition and tell me it's the biggest
the greatest the most different
experience gears can you please can you
just tell me one thing I just say yes or
no and if you not gonna argue with
either way you entitled this do you
think what you saw Gamescom look like
the biggest the most different
experience and gears ever from what you
saw in those two 3cg eyes it looked like
gears for continued CGI story that's
what they show her face contorted right
show that the antagonist looks like they
might go even regardless what you show
do you worry how does it develop how
does a game like progress I mean he'll
you may have never had any kind of trend
moving from area to area like in that
like the right there is different that's
never been in gears right I mean well we
didn't know but hold on oh we didn't
know from that CGI though we didn't know
that the skip was gonna bring the skiff
could have been like the motorcycle
season for
in the past that there were gonna be hub
worlds like they are just because they
didn't show it we can't believe it they
told us it before but we didn't say
anything baby
he said biggest the greatest they didn't
say any they have prompted on that
before about the skip when they showed
it in the very earth trailer would she
had it L wouldn't when it was in the
very first trailer with her going they
calmed it at that III saying there will
take two years ago I'm supposed to
remember this it's not you got it music
I don't know how you do marketing go
ahead movie marketing 101 as a business
owner and you know provider this is what
you have to do you have to show what you
want to make you the most money that's
single player making nobody no cash
mooch all right so we want to I can
drive with David David I can driving
muchas him you know just you know what
you want to do in this current age is
get that residual bucks yes okay so the
residual bucks doesn't lie in a one
playthrough of a story that you might
have to get a play plus that's true and
you know play it on hard just to get a
shield um shout out the Gears of War
what you want is you want to get those
residual bucks now I was just a tweeting
little Texan Aaron last night and they
were doing the Halo event halo outpost
and also at the halo outpost they had um
it was playing tournament games if you
saw the servers that they had lined up
for these tournament games and the
crowds of people that were out there
playing this one game that is tournament
worthy making dollars over dollars over
dollars okay all right this is what they
want now the road map going in was
showing you the new mode that's
multiplayer that can get your friends
and everybody involved that can get game
pass to the point where everybody is
playing game past hours over hours on
end I saw some people on
timeline showing me their gears playtime
one dude had 300 hours and they were
shaming him for 300 hours this other
dude had over 5,000 hours in playing
gears something like how is he doing it
then when you look it was all the
multiplayer can't get because you made a
hell of a point but I think you as a
businessman are gonna respect these next
words I say more than anybody okay when
you're trying to get that money
mm-hmm you don't neglect the other half
they weren't like that money and let me
hold up hold up hold up write that multi
player you're talking about with Aaron
and what's going on with Halo and what's
going on with gears and all those people
and at 5,000 hours that's all there
anyway what I'm saying to you is that
money's already there no now what you
got to do now what you got to do is you
got to go get the other 50% let's say I
don't play that
I don't play multiplayer I play gears
for the story I want to know what this
progression is how are you opening up
the map how am I gonna take my weapons
and store them as I continue and oh wait
hold up girl summer say you don't want I
just got I just got yelled at in the
chat for showing you what I want so we
no no no I want what you want but I
don't want to see everything ahead of
time but kit King King I'll not ask any
Nance for the plot reveal okay all right
s4 show me something between you know
except for ducky copper shoot okay
so rush in you is that money I'm all
about that and everything you said is
gospel ever
what is gospel what I'm telling you is
though that money's there now it's like
yes like you opening up a business be
like none only you guys can buy this not
you got no you want to have the multi
player crowd and the single player
cropper moves and they make my status by
the single player folk not my fight
riders Wi-Fi to you is what did they
show you the the single-player mode they
didn't show it to you when you wanted it
but did they show it to you oh come on
King no no listen I feel I'm with you
I don't with you in that car me and you
were in that car because I wanted to see
I said that too when I was dead
you heard my fight oh right but when I
have to remove myself from my wants to
understanding what position this company
is in that's when you tell you have to
remove yourself from that factor you
know you gonna free the last of us gonna
show you single-player single-player
crap you know why yes because they are
winning they're winning they're gonna
show you their strengths you know and
then they gonna attack awesome but
they're gonna show them all but is that
multiplayers hopefully banking on for
bridge that's concerning King because
now you're telling me from with your
story you're telling me to single
players tacked on Oh for you know apples
apples you're saying no no the Last of
Us - they're gonna show the quality
forthcoming of what their customer wants
in the single player and then they'll
tack on the multiplayer now you're
saying it's the reverse and what I'm
saying to you it's not the reverse
people play gears for the story just as
much as they play for the multiplayer
it's different the Last of Us - it's not
apples to apples as apples to oranges
the other thing you said is you got to
step back and realize what we're talking
about now and what their plan was let me
ask you this King that's like having a
homework assignment that was due on
Wednesday and you turn it in on Thursday
and the teacher says I'm a teacher says
I'm gonna discredit you fret you go no
wait you say when you wanted it but
listen you to show it way before five
days before listen I'm sorry mooch but I
I was privy to their roadmap right now
after seeing that I was really rude yes
when ice went out what I saw Yeah right
why are you worrying about I was really
rude if you go back and look at it I was
really rude and then I was privy to
their road map and they were planning in
August to show you the single player so
that was one month one month out but
what they're building the road map had
the first showing of it to be September
6 the original road map they changed it
and said that they would show it during
Gamescom after some of the backlash oh
no
the original rubber map showed the
singleplayer reveal September 6 that's
the day it comes out no that's the
homework due the next day you can maybe
working I know where you're coming from
and I write sales pitch I really do but
to be honest with you I got if meeting
you were doing this and this was I mean
you were running the coalition dude
right
there's no way me and you were wait
until the day comes out to show the work
we just put our blood sweat and pixels
into that like as we say to the super
chance I think your orders up this how I
look at this whole situation right like
I'm with you like we all record like
addicts solve we walked out of the
Microsoft data we got it up or irony we
were pissed we were like why didn't they
show this campaign we found that was I
right this is III the biggest media
stage all eyes on you you know people
want to see this they ended up yes on
the other modes no stuff so I was in
complete disagreement I just put that
out there as this thing has developed
right I'm not saying I agree with what
they're doing right I'm sure it's just
giving me the impression now that this
was all part of this like scheduled
marketing cadence so it's like you know
we're gonna show the mislead new mode
here III then this event we're gonna
show them this and then we're gonna roll
it all Rockets red glare Gamescom and
give them the campaign you know Sam
right right right now you know the vibe
I'm getting is because I think it's one
of those things King well you know you
feel you got something when tucked and
you know what this is a banger right I
almost knew they were almost too
confident in what they had that they
could market it in this piecemeal kind
of way and they campaign last Ukraine
I'm saying yeah because you know what
they knew that that was their strength
right but you gotta understand the
problem is this is where I saw what
mooch now is because of the state of
Xbox first-party because you know we
haven't had a lot of bangers to really
hold our head about the fan base was
desperate and Sony wasn't there
so now be like you'll give us some good
throws a cracker know something knows it
like we won when you wanted the slow-mo
back slap finisher
we came because if they would have sure
not seen it would have been the greatest
III they would but it would have got the
piece here's why cut here's why the
kognito says is holding a lot of water
real quick with me is because let's just
take a real quick sports reference for
everybody right sports starting up real
soon when you saw Bill Belichick decide
to run a couple years ago with two tight
ends ever it's like who the hell runs
with two tight ends on the line this is
unheard of the man's got rings
the man's got championships so when you
say let's go ahead and believe in this
structure that they put forward for
their marketing and when they wanted to
release it like kognito just said they
are in a form of like I wouldn't use the
word damage control but they are in a
situation right now where they've got a
bill trust back up in their xbox like
brother and right so you can't come out
there with this real risk a form of
marketing like you've been running the
show but you know you're not running the
show you're right but you know what I
think it is I honestly do feel like they
had it scheduled with Lou to say that's
when we're going to do it and I think
that was the slow to go error I think
they should have shown us still a little
some I'm convinced man because at the
what the way this thing is set up you
can't tell me that they look that rod
they had two team in their coalition's
like y'all say like yeah we got one we
got one they know they have one so I'm
day like I we got all these modes what
what's that the one that they showed at
e3 was it three player with neighbor yes
Ward then nobody gave us they even gave
us the beta first on a multi player
right yeah they date to me I just
screamed a little too confident and what
they had and they just kind of missed it
tell me what you guys think I want to
hear with addict and wit
I gotta say I felt like it was a little
too like when we played I played I don't
know about you guys I gotta feel like
level 30 something I played the tech
test to death right yeah I felt like it
was too much of the same and that's
where my concern was I'm like okay so
they're not showing me anything
different yes I'm seeing the story
progressing the CGI I got that never
doubted them they're right now I'm
playing two weekends of tech test which
feels like years for multiplayer let's
be honest cool what it is right and now
I'm still not seeing anything then like
King says they switch up the script and
they said let's
and we're gonna show you some gameplay
after we hear you we hear you we go
there I tune in the games come live I
listen to it what do I see I see more
CGI with maybe about 10 seconds of what
you would call in-game gameplay right
and here we are and think again until
jazz put out his piece I didn't know so
what I'm saying to you is it felt like
like Cognito saying it felt like they
were too cocky they're walking in there
with their chest out and we're kind of
like wait wait a minute you're telling
me this is the biggest baddest
interpretation of gears that were ever
about to sit down experience I believe
you rod cuz the passions bleed and out
right but you gotta show me something
and we don't see it til five days before
it's just like you said I think cog
needles point puts it in a much more
clear perspective they came out thinking
they were gonna be you know they with a
Bill Belichick but when it came down to
it I want to see this point in defensive
yes is that you know we all agree I
think we all agree with the messaging
the timing of it would campaign you know
was law okay but the thing I want to say
though the other narrative that I'm
seeing going around that I disagree with
though is because it wasn't shown at e3
that somehow that meant ultimately the
campaign is spooky that everything about
them is spooky because let's be real
like years for still was a solid game
and there's still a great studio
absolute wasn't really I'm gonna throw I
was talking some people in the Chadians
I don't want proton my under but they
know who they are they're in the chat
but you don't they were like y'all I
don't know you don't saying and I'm like
listen if this was brand-new studio
studio a studio B we never heard of
missed a first game they're not showing
their trailer they're showing other
stuff then I'm like yo this thing could
be really crazy but with coalition for
me it's like it's innocent till proven
guilty you know
I got a respect rod in the team and what
they built before I go complete complete
although I can understand concern that I
would you know it's definitely gonna be
trashed like I'm willing that part I'm
riding with you on everything you said
Cognito but my question is is do you
think that you could put that faith not
just on the resume and the pedigree that
is the coalition and rod but let's also
be honest here right let's get it right
you're playing gears 5 for $0.99 oh yeah
absolutely
now would you want to see more if it was
$60 plus tax in your respective state so
my point being is it's easy to say what
you just said because I'm gonna sit
there and go [ __ ] I lost 99 cents in the
couch cushions last language so when I'm
saying news it's easy for me to ride
with cagney nose last pitch because he
made a good pitch he's saying mooch put
all your worries aside it's time to just
believe in what we know and I don't know
wait let me shut you down right there
because no I'm not saying put all your
worries aside I've got saying that you
hate had a right to be some concern
because there can't be one shown but I
heard people not you I heard other
people saying whenever there's no
campaign showing it's automatically
gonna be trash and down I wasn't known
as oh and you listen this is just so
everyone knows in the checkers come
people here that they make their
opinions up of each of us wrong with me
for like 17 years you know what I mean
first of all I never said that right and
I've said that there's probably nobody
on the Microsoft payroll that's got the
passion and love for a game like Rod
Fergusson so I've said that a number of
times and I'll say it again on this show
so first of for most no because I don't
see gameplay footage doesn't mean it's
true yeah that's insanity
let me jump in here real quick shout out
the big cloud game and happy a belated
birthday brother
listen I hear it and I watched all the
fear-mongering in that soil and stuff
and trust
when I was at the e3 respect that 107 is
rolling in there that's beautiful I
button here to retweet this dad boy are
we talking out here where when when I
was at e3 and LF I had a opportunity to
talk to Phil now you gotta understand
that's my guy mm-hmm like you got to
understand that and you know we when
your boy thought he balled out but you
were sitting on the bench and you
realized he really didn't ball out like
me wanted him to ball out all right so I
said then he was like yo you know blow
up the shirt yeah you know I in-law boom
bang and he's like yo so what you
thought about the joint and I told him I
said we're not gonna talk about that
right now you know this is this is your
moment there's a lot of people online
I'm gonna talk to you let them talk to
you i'ma holla at you later you know and
you know timbers with me people's with
me hey man I said I'm emotional at this
point right good point good point you
know because at this point in time I
want my leader to go up there and crush
these dudes now
I'm privy to the fact that I didn't know
that he had a backdoor deal giving
service to dudes okay I didn't know that
you know they had deals on deck putting
games on other systems right so when you
get to that political story you don't
don't forget when I came back from e3 I
called them fill political yes all right
and don't don't think that I don't see
the movements that you have to make
right you never want to get too big in
this industry that you're constricted
from being you that's right up until
that point we wanted Phil to go in and
dominate all Xbox people I'm talking
from my xboxone fanboy ISM now don't get
it wrong I got every thing okay I got a
system over here I got 6,000 games I got
everything and I play everywhere what I
choose to play with who I'm comfortable
with who I will put my credit card on
Xbox okay so you have to understand
watching them I'm fighting for the
underdog didn't underdog if they're
coming up this was the moment that Rocky
was supposed to knock Drago out right
and he didn't and with his big gun he's
supposed to throw that left hook and
busts his jaw wide open his left hook
was Gears of War you showed her campaign
ko ko right he's not really done like
with Bloody gloves yep and he didn't do
it and you're telling him man why didn't
you throw the left breathing this man's
gonna get up and we know what he do when
he get a second win mm-hmm and it seemed
like Sony started getting me a win and
our hearts just fell to the floor cuz
you had a mouth champ and now they're
showing you what you wanted to see but
it was too late because you already
recovered right because because the
stage was set I think you're right I can
you like what it is
the stage was set because we knew Sony
wasn't there all right so you know the
marketing blitz it's gonna be the
biggest baddest and everyone wants blood
well the crowd is like finish them this
is us this is our moment and we instead
we got like a 12-round decision safe you
know do whatever whatever we got a floor
you may what the spreadsheet we got a
difference we got defensive wizardry we
got all this versatility but we want it
blood was an emotional thing from from
an Xbox perspective I do I were you
going for that's a great reference but
adding I want to get you in on this I
know you were very or at it going jumped
out for something better but everybody
comes back well yeah man this this was a
hot-button topic I think mooch you
definitely killed this man so much going
on and yeah but all we just hope is that
you know it reviews well you know right
now my absolutely my guess what you
thinking my mooch thing like
I got I had an I had an 88 89
you know I it could break 90 to be
honest with you it's got it's got all
the work it's for that but I want to
take a step back real quick you know
because something you said I know you
wanna get to another subject but real
quick I think what's healthy here and I
always am advocate for this know this I
don't even know the fear monger it's
about great healthy conversation cuz you
want oh something I learned something
from King yeah right I pick something up
from you attic the thing about it is
this we have to we have to have we have
a talk show right and people are in your
chat right now saying this shows fire
this is lit this is entertaining sois
come right they love your show they love
what we do we do these shows I do three
shows a week you do shows you do spot
shows you do spot appearances you do
your streaming right we have to have
discussions people we can't get on here
and just play King what do you think I
think it's great
mooch about you great Cognito great next
subject right like we have to have
emotions and we have to have we've also
been gaming we've said this when we did
when you do your intros which is so
healthy and so great that it introduces
the people that you have on your show
kognito okay okay let people know the
background of each individual and where
they came up from what I think
everybody's got in common we're almost
like in a fraternity every one of us
that's on YouTube we are all brothers
because one thing that we all did is we
all grew up together we all grew up
playing games and that's one thing that
nobody could take away from anybody on
this panel or any other panel that's the
one thing that I have to come up across
because when people like no mooch is
just saying this because no no nobody on
this panel is getting a cut of the money
nobody all we want is the best product
to enjoy our best and probably our most
favorite have a pastime of our lives so
that's what I'm saying so we come
together every week to have these great
discussions and that's why I called the
show crossfire don't come on oh come on
crossfire agreeing with me fact about
this man weave me I love that most
people don't like to be challenged and
that's what I love about what you do and
I respect crossfire in a sense that and
you bring people on that
we'll have the absolute opposite figured
I know it because I know yes and I was
thoroughly impressed on today she look
like I say Oh Lucas my girl she was out
there everybody was in there with strong
points and it was great healthy
discussion and that's what we need to
have healthy oh we got Lord Eric Jackson
in a building from rap podcast and a
game let's go sir you should have intro
music remember when Vanilla Ice is
walking around every time he walked the
room yet intro music I love the grown
man gaming talk of this podcast yes sir
JD game with two dollars which at this
show is fine folks hit that like button
I agree JD Mike Jackson man what's going
on brother
Oh real quick take on the whole gears v
thing I know I know just been talked at
nauseam but we got to get you to sense
man you know actually yeah I'm lose put
it like perfectly man it's like after
reading Jess's coverage of her oven I
was more on fire about it yeah along
with the trailer that they finally
showing you know I was I was the only
people I was like majorly concerned I
did say I wanted to see more campaign at
e3 but it wasn't like it was the doom
and gloom I was like it's gonna be what
its gonna be it's on them that oppressed
me
mm-hmm not the other way around I'm not
worried we got bigger I got a storm
breathing down my neck
those are issues you worry about you
know facts a game is a game we got
plenty to play right oh but after what
drop in the impressions that we're
seeing yeah that get hype sort of
building up again yeah you know saying
something I'm definitely looking forward
to jumping in again it's on them mm-hmm
yeah this I'll never hit the homerun
it's like King was saying you know you
got to get back up off the mat mm-hmm
and you need these wins so start hitting
these home runs don't know weekend
cameras how the gamers the real gamers
have amnesia
yes different bangers it's like they
don't even remember when y'all were like
in the BJ you
just mail whatever I had this cow say
with someone really close and that's
exactly what I said I said bro at the
end of the day
gamers are figure right you're like
people are not loyal in this sense like
another soul body keeps putting out
bangers that's where the people are
going that's just is so and again we
know Microsoft is generation we know
what's going on you know I'm saying for
me person I just wanted them to end
strong we know how to generation yes
right just finish on a strong note give
you got your community something to be
excited about coming into scarlet so now
it's like you got a little conference so
I like you said you nailed it perfectly
arrogant a sense that like all you gotta
do is make bangers cuz everything else
has forgotten people forget everything
about extra you can you bake bangers
it's on you know said I think I think
that is so key you know for the a lot of
these uh for the big three in general
but that's all I got hopefully I didn't
come back cuz this is his topic but
we're gonna get it going anyway um yeah
tell-tell studios y'all um a lot going
on man I mean shout-out to LCG
entertainment you know they've been sort
of a revival you know a lot of the
assets were bought and um we've heard
reports of some original telltale play
people coming back although under
contract you know stuff like that
so it's a real polarizing thing right
now because um you know on one hand you
have people who are really happy when
they heard the news telltale is a bluff
studio and on the other hand you know
I've even seen boycotts you know that
this is not right based on you know the
corporate structure of the past regime
and how sheisty econo was that people
lost their job so I want to bring this
to the realm as got started on much you
know telltale games Minh when you heard
of the news of them coming back and
under the circumstances like where
where's your head at with this head
expect oh oh my bad good adding me it's
your topic was good over um you know I
wanted to actually branch us out into a
couple things one I wanted to get
everyone's perspective on the the
overall genre in this like do you think
that cuz you know I just played until
Dawn's new game do you think that this
type of gameplay is even relevant
anymore
bring Russian let me comment because um
I'm a big telltale fish let's listen
we can't front telltale like shut up -
don't not entertainment square with the
life of strange and all that but we
can't front tail tail was - oh gee
Annette and it's time they were doing
something that had never been done like
almost i'ma show my age here mooch but I
don't know if you I remember on choose
your own adventure books yes yeah number
dolls he says if you pick this turn to
page 55 if you pick that turn like my
problem with those books talkin you know
not to interrupt you with I've burned to
the page I was like on all that shit's
gonna suck for me little I lords
earmuffs never work for me because I
would always fast forward to the right
any we got MOOCs the best any go ahead
you got to resist the temptation to find
out I know
oh it's like for me at the time like
attic you know like tales of the
borderlands now I wasn't even in the
portland's but I remember watching that
drain that got me into universe um elf
among us you know what I'm saying I went
there from Raiders backs King for me
what did it was The Walking Dead
the story of Clementine and Lee and if
you ended that game if you ain't had no
heart in you if you ain't feel a little
bit of a way of how well that was
written so for me I'm always gonna have
a little feel for them but then I gotta
be real too much in a sense that they
started to get down his path of same
ikana games yeah it's not to get down
this path of that engine a really
updating family and then you starting to
like club chase Game of Thrones Oh novel
Batman Gordy's guy remember they was
like everything they was wrong it was
like they was doing too much same story
different skin it didn't work out we get
bored the audience I thought it wasn't I
don't even think it bored the audience
what I think happen is they would lose
out their chance of doing something like
ain't nobody they should have like did
the whole season they should have been
fast and adapted to it now I think
there's a couple ways they could've did
it they could have made sure that the
because they had their team split
between like seven different projects or
six or whatever you know they could've
did too
and had someone like it had these
episodes have to come out once every
month
it can't didn't know once year six an
episode three months from now because by
the time it gets to that second episode
people were on by the first one always
need names once you get to that second
one it's three minutes later you gain
doesn't even exist to us anymore like so
I felt like they could've did that or
they could've did what I would have
wanted them to do is just release the
whole season at once right and I think
you right I mean attic in a sense to is
like they kind of got in love with this
marketing stretch schedule of like
hitting you with episode you got away
and all that you you robbed me all this
stuff like to about the other day I mean
from what we found out you know up at
the top there was just a lot of
mismanagement financially so I mean what
you think um
EJ like where were you at with that as
well with um with telltale no it was you
hit it on the head man I said the same
thing they they came in strong when they
you know they well I should say they
made a little bit of a name with
Bachelor future and stuff like that
right here but where they really
skyrocketed was when they did The
Walking Dead and part of that was the
wave of where Walking Dead was at the
time along with that it was the perfect
license and then it's almost like you
said they got stuck in this rut of will
just keep doing their with licenses and
that can work up a to a point but then
people want to start seeing hey maybe
you guys should do something like
original but then you know what happened
supermassive came in and ate their lunch
that's how I look at it Esther came in
to a door and people like yo that's what
when these games can look like oh right
that engine PlayStation TN what's
fantastic and then yeah and then it just
made it just made that that telltale
engine look bad cuz I actually argue
that one of my favorite games from there
that's did their best game that largely
got ignored it was the one among all
wolf appeal and I was like Raiders game
over for them that game was fired that
game was amazing
you know but we move into their
generation and you still had the same
engine look when I run around with that
Ford engine
you know if you want to drop off a
Mustang any time you could do it but
change the engine pull up next to you
later oh you got some popular in the
engine and you pull off the sound like a
lawnmower engine pulling up with the
Hellcats and and one great engine
because these dues until dawn pulled up
with their Ferrari engine this is really
what it's supposed to look and I believe
that wasn't really did downfall of you
know well you know I got no I think he's
spot-on to be honest with you I thought
that if you want to talk about telltale
getting revitalized and getting reborn
there's no company other than and it can
they could've picked it up on the cheap
as far as I'm concerned this is perfect
for Microsoft yeah and hear me out right
I'm gonna go ahead oh you know umbrella
umbrella Academy two is coming out and I
can't wait for daredevil to lose now is
going to Disney Plus but nonetheless you
got all these things coming out right
this is or stranger things for people
gotta be there so all of a sudden you
get the new Walking Dead you get whoops
amongest to right these are things you
have to continuously dip your feet back
in the game past whether you use it for
the bangers or not you're going there
for these games and let me tell you
something this is a moneymaker
this is one of those things that's a
hook and sinker so you get your customer
to continuously go back in the ball and
it makes your customers say you know
what I'm gonna do the year-long just
game pass because the fact is I want to
know when the next series comes out I
have to know what happens in this
progression right so these are the
things that I think Microsoft should be
like looking for instead of like the
Blair Witch is of the world spend your
money on telltale or those types of
things get people for continuation that
was when I saw now myself personally not
late you said early in the show let's
take a step back let me just get out of
that that's the marketing and that's the
business end of it as far as me the
gamer I mean yes I like what until dawn
I like everything that King said was
facts they brought that to the next
level yeah but telltale after the
initial Walking Dead yeah and after the
wolf's among us it felt like not only
was the engine old I think they just
dialed it in yeah right a fella - it
almost noise you could play it with a
pirate's patch on you know yeah you were
like noting are you joy coming out and
you're like okay you know what about it
they really I don't I can't really think
of a bad game they made to like I can't
like all of them well told they were
good story they were good games they
didn't issue that they had is they had
companies like Square Enix making life
is strange that did what they did better
better their companies like super masses
that did what they did better and they
never try to compete with them they just
kept trying to do what they're doing
yeah I want to bring this back to moose
before I give it to King um what do you
feel mooch about that the continuously
decide that I mean there's a legit
boycott going on right now you know I'm
saying where they like yo don't support
this romantic reanimated corpse of a
telltale they laid off their staff got
snapped up 80 millionaires and now
they're hiring people back as
freelancers without benefits get your
names I see I mean this is a person who
tweeted at polygon this is not polygon
saying sorry could be right right right
I think that this is interesting because
I'm glad you brought that up cut you
know i-i've said that this is something
that they would probably do I just said
it actually on M and C this morning I
said you have a big wig company go out
there scoop this up on the cheap they're
gonna go out there get all the nostalgia
factor for people that now having played
a telltale game in a minute and they're
gonna say you know what I'm all down for
this I'm gonna pay I'm gonna put that
thirty forty dollars out there scoop it
up and then they're gonna drop it right
so it's a quick investment it's like
picking up a stock that's hot right
right mm-hmm
Bing blast it you split if the stock
splits you make all that money will you
do the mick sell that stock so this is
you know so I don't really blame people
for feeling that my advice is this it's
kind of a neutral stance on it and my
stance is look at the product yes if
it's a product you want to play I listen
boycotting and all that that ain't gonna
you know people say ball boy
Walmart weeks ago still took me like
eight eros till I could find a parking
spot ain't nobody going cotton Walmart
right nobody's boycott Walmart so my
point is is like no one's gonna boycott
this game but if the game Atrus you play
the game if it doesn't and it looks like
a quick grab just to make a couple
dollars just like I did with the last 15
or they made it's a hard pass yeah
great King let's get you in on his get
that a super check real quick
Eagles about the job oh yeah Eagle my
brother follow super Chad peace to
everyone in the realm panel and Chad
have a great day I got a head out taking
the kids to the movies that's what some
take the little Lords to the movies
that's what's up but you have met King
okay now for this boycott thing let's
not support the reanimated corpse to
dead shell listen a lot of times what
y'all understand and a lot of companies
a lot of guys are gone and then somebody
else comes and purchases the name and
then put out stuff under that name so
when you gonna boycott that one thing
boycott everything don't shoot boycott
be for real you know Livius what happen
the Nordic yeah oh what I'm say what
this is um you say maybe hiring them as
freelancers but they were out of work
yeah hiring these guys don't capacity
that they hiring them they're working so
don't sit there and boycott these guys
working because you're boycotting them
working so me join is based off for
their performance so you're out here
talking about you're gonna boycott the
people that you want to support this is
when you're talking out of both sides of
your mouth hmm
let the game come out you don't even
know what game that they're doing they
might do a game that just truly
interested in but you don't backed
yourself into a corner yelling now from
the highest mountain and I'm gonna
boycott them but they're playing your
game now they do em game for you when
you send they're like oh good back on my
word now you eatin crow now people on
Twitter beating the brakes off for you
and let it play out not everybody needs
to be heard right
okay no as far as don't go listen mama
my hard drive crash this week you guys
know that I'm reinstalling my games I
have
a boatload of telltale games didn't get
to because I was playing wolf among us
that Batman have the guardians I have
the Game of Thrones yeah I have all of
them so when I was downloading them I
said yo I'm getting back into that to
finish that off and in playing these
games I realized how great they were
so when certain people looked up and saw
them coming back and they were like oh
man
I was elated at the fact now to muchas
point then said that is supposed to be
in-game pass yeah no brainer not good so
very smart but I think that the girl
that they have with life is strange
really does something to that deal want
it to be let's say you got 200 games and
game passed you don't want 40 of those
games to be tell type games right so
then that takes show you what your
diversity is to a different population
so I don't I don't know like the
business end of it but what but I like
it that yes what would you feel if they
took on that company and they gave them
Microsoft IPs to do in game press why
like a fable books and books and books
on Halo why not make a series of that
they could explore the lore aspect you
know I'm saying I just want to come and
there you know there's a lot about the
war that Marcus was in that we don't
know about they could do that stuff no I
just want to come up with quick as King
made a good point as far as the people
being hired right and stuff like that
and it was a good account on a probably
gonna Kadima Blee was uh Jessica leave
excuse me by Sarah Guinness so pretty
but she was like one of the directors of
Rizzoli with the original telltale got
let go but now she's being brought on by
the new company that problem brought
them back and she interesting stuff to
say she was like her title remains the
same there's just so slight differences
between a role and stuff like that and
then she said her goal is to avoid
repeating the mistakes of the old
company to honor the original telltale
staff and more positive history telltale
so know
people asked her about the reactions
like the negative thing with the boycott
she's like look I understand it she said
it would be she said I just wish it
would be nice at least to see innocent
until proven guilty approach here
you said objectively we have two leaders
in a group of additional investors who
truly believe that Telltale's games can
have an abrupt and avoidable end and
decided to scoop them up and bring this
brand and product back to the active
market how could anyone not applaud this
move I think it's both wise and
courageous to take the tell-tale brand
work and bring it rise it back like a
phoenix so she's very happy about it a
lot of people are saying that yes some
of them must you know they are contract
work but there's other accounts again in
this polycon article people are saying
oh this is this is very positive I
wouldn't sign up for it if a shot to the
car's driver yes oh it's kind of who's
that up for it if it wasn't a fair deal
and there's they saying real positive
things matter this is coming from the
employee you know what it might be it
might be - might be the fact that when
they left as a company was such bad
stigma people were just assuming it's
happening in same people again okay I
mean I want to say yeah I mean maybe you
know give people a chance to learn from
the mistake like she said you know a if
they go out and do the same exact thing
again like you said King said take him
to task right you know but it's but this
whole jumping ahead I'm by the boycott
I'm done and outraged culture is it's
like I said on I play this game like I
think they should do the season approach
right where they should release the
entire season like three months later
they released and I think they should
stay to the same game until that story's
fully concluded because playing the The
Walking Dead Season three or four or
whatever the one there one like seven
years later it didn't have the same
effect when I played it the first one
but if that game was out the third year
after it came out I would still have
that nostalgia filling it just wasn't
there yeah I agree with Tweetie they did
space those out way too long especially
that was their you know their their
crime yeah that was the one you know I'm
saying so I'm with you man let's move on
we got a couple more times to get on oh
yeah
we got its mom up so we got an astral
chain out in the streets man a lot of
stuff going on and I want to approach it
from two point perspective I'm gonna
stop with the fraud alert King I see you
stopped with tuck keep it tough we not
gonna do that right now on two fronts
one I'll just briefly you know explain
my experience for the gang because I'm
assuming a lot of the panel did not pick
it out that's why my man EJ's in here so
let's get that out the way her a smooch
it all you frauds they didn't probably
cop it but it's cool I'll just ease it
but all jokes aside I mean you know as
far as astral we know the history we
know is platinum all that good stuff and
for me personally you know I've been
keeping for this thing since I first saw
it the direct like a couple months ago
so long yeah man it's just classic
platinum you know over-the-top style is
she I'm saying but the thing that
surprised me was just this really deep
chain system that you have with that
legion that you're attached to so that
was really cool I think what was dope
King it's you're gonna like like it's
literally like an afternoon cartoon like
it's like bro when you start the game
there's a theme song bro it's like you
go you came home from school Saturday
morning what car - are you watching
Silverhawks a Thundercat like this is
that I'm like how - hero gotta be you so
like and it's real live band y'all I
guess it's crazy so you got that good
all right now shout out to the music in
the game yo eg the police station beat
the club bangers feeling it you know and
the thing that really surprised me was
two things one they have this detective
investigative thing right yeah it's kind
of you you know you want your cop
investigation you're putting close
together you're putting stuff together
like real police then you got this other
part obviously with the action which is
more Devil May Cry - stylish
over-the-top the boombastic all that and
then also you got the own platforming
which I didn't expect I didn't expect
there's gonna be any platform man so I
think what really took it on for me
again I'll give it to you is that on the
tutorial because when I did tutorial I
didn't realize how deep the
was and I literally just thought it with
some simple hack and slash like King
they talked about you can attach a man
to the chain right relegion you can have
that you control the Legion with the
right animal you can have him wrap
around somebody lock them up and then
y'all get you our business on or like if
big bosses come at you yak you could
separate from your legion create like
this line and catch them like a rubber
band and fling them back like fam
it is so fired at McCann you feel our
worldly you feel like you you you doing
some exploding they slow it down and
start effect is like okay I see what
you're doing wrong you know thought
about this this is a unique thing this
is not like some joint that you seen
before after I want to stress the people
talking you know how's the game holding
up though as far as the switches it may
it could let me tell you something I've
seen a lot of video I've seen a lot of
video on it and no you're right I did
not buy this game but it is it has made
the mooks radar I'm not gonna lie to you
but I will say this much I'm slightly
concerned when I see that amount of
action platforming like I said like the
effects to color the light particles but
I see all that happening on a switch I
played games on a switch I get a little
concern to do as far as the frame rate
with 30 yeah a lot but the thing I will
give you is you know switch with the
anti-aliasing I think it's actually more
worse when you put it in dock cuz in in
in handheld I was okay but when my dock
certain center max looks fantastic but
then you start to see the roughness of
certain stuff but I will say there's a
ton of stuff going on and from what I
experienced honey I didn't have a locker
but I may be able to eat job but talk a
lot EJ you've been playing for a couple
hours and stuff like that no you you
kinda brought you on like where is your
head with actual chain yeah like you say
this it's all the way platinum it is the
but it's the from what I'm telling so
far it's the best of platinum it's the a
squad right but all those things are in
there it's not come on King you just let
me know is they squad yeah
we have the a squad and you have the
bench and you know you know you know
what the best can deliver from platinum
writing mm-hmm so but there's definitely
some thought that went into like the
gameplay mechanics of what they're doing
like I'm up I'm a fan of bayonetta but I
will admit Bayonetta is it can't kind of
be you know you put it on autopilot at
times you know you just rockin the combo
you make sure the dodge now the dodge
mechanic is here but they've also made
it to where you're not gonna just spam
the dodge yes because they will crowd
you and they will make you pay for yes
you have to think out methodically where
the arena is what you're doing and use
those mechanics I dunno for [ __ ] using
you're not gonna just keep you know
spamming the attack button or whatever
it's like you've gotta use your Legion
mm-hmm you know and the different things
that are teaching and the mechanic of it
is this a little learning curve to it
right like you're not gonna just jump in
and be like you know like Beeston it and
being like a master at it you know
saying you you really have to think out
okay I got this to use I got bad to use
and how bad you know that comes out now
the one thing like mooch was asking
about how you know it's handling the
frame rates and stuff like that it was a
smart idea to go with the cel-shaded
like smash mm-hmm that's very much a
benefit it's like they knew Jimmy
equipment that they were working with
yep you know would it shine probably a
lot more on a ps4 Xbox one it absolutely
um but it's definitely not doing
anything and I'm like like you know Cox
said early on it's pushing a lot of
stuff at you I don't know what's coming
up later thanks for starting off is
throwing a lot at you pretty much as far
as that aspect but I what I want to
bring to the to the rest of y'all is
that at home as far as the perils that
you know what surprised me I wanna shout
out my man stealth 40k you know saying
god I want to show before you know done
a lot of internal analytics before and
this really surprised me y'all he
basically said cuz right now believe
Astrachan is sitting at about an 87
Metacritic E and what they said is that
it is being review bomb people are
giving it zeros and a lot of it stems on
the fact that it's a platinum
Nintendo switch exclusive right no
craziness going on where you got like a
time you look at medical there's a ton
of zeros from the user rating and then
you'll see
that'll of PlatinumGames are firing back
and then giving it all tense
so like better critic right now boots is
not what after you know that does you
know what it does though I need I need
you to read that super check more here
we go what petty best about walking into
Tulsa has better frame rate than this
Ridge salute to Lois ditch for always
being petty honest I think you're onto
something probably better than the
switch does Oh disrespectful right here
actually it does though actually I saw
Aaron playing covered in this low boy
said you gotta admit I'll or podcast and
Eric the whole first chapter is that Lee
like Mass Effect twisted still remind
you was a platinum game it's got some
weird yeah got some platinum you know
from the rib absolutely but I wanna get
better real quick though as far as that
the whole review bombing and then you
know because people it's an exclusive to
Nintendo and the last thing you know
before I'm gonna give us which um to
mooch is that the thing that he made
clear as far as stealth was that he was
saying that like platinum was gonna go
under his I'm a you quoted exactly he
said clapper was very close to it as
calmly I once said the financial
bankruptcy if you're a true fan of
studio you want them to get any cyber
success platinum game seriously could
have gone permanently under if near
autumn Isle wasn't successful
they found a partner in in tendo who's
willing to bankroll games that they
develop because they're an extremely
talented studio if it keeps the lights
on it's a good thing so yeah now he's
really animate about this thing but much
where you at with this review bombing
stuff well first of all I think this is
why and I've said this a number of times
and I'll say it again we can have a
great calm it is great conversation on
any podcast to talk about meta scores
because let's be honest its reviews
right if it's it's a basis of at least
breaking the ice on a certain game but I
don't put a whole lot of faith into it
one of the games I had the most fun
playing this year was days gone and it
got a 71 right so what does that means I
mean I didn't have a good time nice
right so that being said I
we'll say this much in this game don't
go by the meta scores this that 87 that
should tell you alone with the the wars
that are going on with meta that this
game is phenomenal if he can still have
an 87 and after white after all you just
said number two what I would normally
say is wait for this game to go on sale
but it's a switch game so even when it
goes on sale $59.99 250 $6.99 on sale
you get from you won't believe it that
game you wanted finally it's on sale I'm
like on sale $3.50 off listen if you
want the game don't wait for a sale just
go get the game because like you know
there is something for the value of
playing it in the now right well
everyone's talking about it
that's what we've always said what have
you done for me lately games right now
and then now enjoy this game while it's
a buzz enjoy this game while there's a
community out there alive I don't put
listen we will always this go away fire
goes for crossfire listen I'm not
backing it up I'm I don't have it what
I'm saying is that like I don't put a
lot of faith right in meta I say it over
and over again your base right it's a
base number roll from there
listen other games on xbox system I've
gotten in the sixties right I think what
is it there 61 62 is with crackdown 3
sitting that I beat crackdown 3 I played
a little bit entirety I had a lot of fun
with it
so does that mean at 62 again mooks
didn't have a good time mm-hmm preaching
who can tell me that right let's use
that meta as a great icebreaker yes but
then we got to take the conversation and
we got to lift it up from there because
that is only a starting point exactly
but the book review bombs can also
backfire a review bombs can send people
to the store yeah yeah I gotta see what
this is about this can't be like what's
going on it can't be that bad right max
asked a Nintendo for sale will land you
in jail for six months when I'm looking
through the Nintendo store like the
Astro chain didn't even light up for me
it's like a blank gray background and it
blends in with the back of the switch
because I don't even see it but
all right listen
tag tag has been champion this game 500
as far as the Metacritic spot I don't
care I like I don't care if I four-game
inside game pass gets a hundred on
Metacritic or two it doesn't dictate
what I'm gonna play how I'm gonna play I
don't really care I don't even look to
it so when y'all telling me that all
these dudes is Metacritic buff you got
too much time on your hands I'm just
trying to measure out my time and
getting into gambit and stuff like that
to do my stuff that I got to do
Moochie and I was just talking off air
but head of time and in the limited time
that we have to gain back I don't have
time to sit there and go trash a game
that I either don't own or don't care to
check out yet or if I do to kit C we
already know as game is what we're
buying regardless to what anyone says he
said something about Zelda I said well
you're buying it and that's on sweets
right okay so that's letting you know
how much of fraud I am because when that
Zelda comes out my switch will turn on
and I'm gonna be upstairs and I'm gonna
be playing it and I'm gonna plan it in
the dark mode I'm not taking it no place
I don't I don't care to get cataracts in
my eyes you guys I have to understand
cog has been champion in this game
sovereign has been champion this game
and I'm just happy to it lived up to
everything that they're talking about
yeah we would have went this was my
little horse that I was baking on and I
was champion in platinum got that
fanbase they do they got that game play
that people like it's like people with
kijima I don't understand why people
like Kojima's games but people why
Kojima's games is what platinum is just
dis that stylish over-the-top like it's
just yeah it's it's um about it EJ I
can't it reminds me of like watching
animes back in the day mm-hm it's like a
live action
Kyra you're a million laughs it's like a
Kyra mix with Guyver and you know just
crazy boombastic stuff and the dialogue
yes it gets ridiculous sometime but I
will say there's no add again the story
is kind of lit with this chimera thing
and I'm taking over the human race and
interdimensional drain it's gonna fire I
can't run so I'm waiting to see where it
goes
that's all I got we got to move on
because I know we got Lord moon she's
got a fantasy Drive we got to get him
out of here school that's a football
yeah we got football man we gotta go oh
hold on guys actually I got a cup off
but um yo getting thanks for let me jump
in Thank You E brother oh no dad looks
like it looks like we might be all right
again but dude every 20 minutes is like
oh no it's coming back
but don't grill real prayers out to the
people who Bahamas that yeah hammer
right now yeah hammer this is the
biggest this is the biggest craziest
storm I've seen since Andrew and that
was like 20 Wow
it's category five it's almost 200
mile-per-hour winds on the outer bands
this is crazy man yeah please so you
have prayers out to people who have
family in Bahamas and and Carolinas look
out because it could be turned that way
too so yeah but uh no thanks all thanks
for all the prayers and thoughts no amen
God you know brother be safe brother you
already know thanks for the phone all
right now too much shout out to my man
Rick we know from my Cali family you
know ant bone shout-out to all you guys
out there real true daddy's real true
friends real true brothers shout out to
him with quaint little snap if you ain't
watching his snap I'm gonna tell you
right now listen Andy his snap isn't lit
that's my dude no gang gang gang gang
gang last one man we got to get out of
here man Lord King one on in these
streets I know yes Omar interesting take
on there so let's get this in man what
you got all right so we all know what
remedy did when he was with Microsoft
right and I believe that was under the
old regime when he was forced to
constructed their game around a TV
montage stuff that made the game fall
flat when they had to switch gears while
I was making the game so I don't think
the game got the proper light now
control is out here and everybody's
talking about control is the sliced
bread
we believe that has a lot to do with the
media bias going towards Microsoft you
know and and the game is being pushed by
Sony with the you know the extra levels
and stuff like that being that they
funded some parts of this game or
something to that nature now you know
just ask some real quick while you're
going like is it me or no one was
talking about control until it was
rumored Sony was buying this company I'm
about to get to the point now um
when the game was showed everybody
mm-hmm another remedy game or whatever
then the rumors started that Sony might
be purchasing this company and then the
game turned into something that oh it's
the best game that they ever put out and
oh my god I can't believe the control in
control and do you understand that
remedy is at a peak form right now that
dancing on them so my question is is
that rhetoric being pushed for them to
sell as is it on paper saying that if
they sell a certain amount or get a
certain Metacritic or certain things and
that nature that the company will be
purchased by Sony I want to know is the
media and pushing the game into throwing
these pockets are we doing it huh you
know sometimes we call something the
perfect storm and I think I think what
King just did was and I'll be honest
with you King would you the way you just
placed all that in that chain of events
that had happened in the proper timeline
I see where you're going with that I
think people could roll with it I really
knew but I will say this much I did not
play Alan Wake so I put that I always
put that out there I did not play that
game
I did play quantum break yes let me tit
I played it through half way again they
try and do the other story missions oh I
got half way through us kind of all
right I've been there done this other
games came out but I went through it not
beat it I will say this much control for
me and only for me I think is remedies
shining light but that's not this the
other two and it's also not to put
King's idea in his in his is the
to the side engineer he's not wrong but
but what I'm saying is is I think that
they had time here I think I think this
time they had time to take the engine
they were just working on with with
quantum break now you're talking about
another three years goes by right for
years had time to build up on that and
also because they went back to not I
don't think 505 games was really over
their shoulder very much I think
Microsoft needed quantum break to launch
maybe it launched a little pre before
ready
who knows that's all stuff that's behind
the scenes we'll never know till
somebody writes a book mm-hmm but I will
say this much I'm probably halfway
through the game and I will say the
combat is much more fluent and more fun
I think than quantum breaks I will say
this much I think the environment even
if it was a shorter development time I
think the environment in quantum break
was much more breathtaking and over
right your eyes just light up when you
turn that corner on quantum break we're
here because the setting is all so far
where I'm playing could expand is within
a building okay and it has it has it has
dungeons and caves and things you're
going to do but don't get me wrong it's
got it's got its moments where it looks
good but really it comes down to the
gameplay and the fact that in quantum
break it was that stutter step blast
freeze time freeze blast right that
pausing effect yeah that took you a
little bit out of it
this game has similar notations by
similar kind of physics but it's fluid
so as you're moving you're lifting
something slamming it shooting from the
hip bop bop-bop-bop swim again bursting
through it's fast it's a faster pace
almost gives you that feeling you get
from like those games that platen puts
up it's that speed you got in this when
I'm sleeping you tight so anyone who's
done the fence right now goes well I
didn't like quantum break too much this
is a clear successor to what Sam Lake
and his people want now get him back to
King's point there's that you know I
kind of went off on the game review side
of it brother go know if he get into his
pipe because his point is valid I mean
it did pick up some steam once we heard
that Sony might acquire them well rumors
mooch with what about those those little
innuendos you so dolls yeah I did I did
and I mean to be honest with you I don't
think that I saw all that stuff that
came from gorilla
James and and all that right they
polluted by all those packages out there
and on the bottom was like I can't wait
to you're acquired see you in September
you know is it going on okay you know we
can all break out the magnifying glass
and see that but the point that matters
I don't I don't think that I don't think
that that necessarily Excel I think the
game has to exceed on its own merits
right so I'll go ahead and take it still
like I said King said earlier in the
show I'm gonna go ahead and I've been
doing this the past couple days as I'm
right in the review up right I gotta
take a step back
I gotta not think green not think blue
right I got to think about the game for
a second and I tell you if this game
sucked if it was beyond playable I don't
care who's buying Apple could have
bought him mmm it doesn't matter the
fact of the matter is it would have just
crashed hard so I think it's and I think
that the the the meta believe it or not
even though we Bashmet it at that yeah I
think the meta that it sits at is it
necessarily a bad score or the wrong
score I think it's sitting right at home
where it should I think it's in that low
80s you guys correct me if I'm wrong but
I think that's kind of where it belongs
um so I mean that's my point so I think
I I can ride with King on his theory but
I will send this much I think that the
game is also the perfect storm as far as
look at the release here's five is next
week Borderlands is the week after let's
be honest to call it what it is man of
Madana my dad that's not gonna stand up
control I'm not playing it it's okay but
I mean it's not gonna it's not gonna
hold a candle to remedy remedies got
that name so when we get into later on
in the conversation when we talk about
maybe acquiring them that's one thing
but let's be honest it's the perfect
storm it's the first triple a game to
launch and really cut the ribbon as we
go into the holiday season right so it's
nothing right people been dry we've been
dry you can say you've been playing your
backlog I beat a couple games in my
backlog but let's be honest it's nothing
like going out there and knowing that
this is the first game then after you
play control you've got a new IP or a
new game coming at you next week
the week after the week after that it's
the beginning of the season you know we
all clamor for this so I think it's the
perfect storm it's a little bit of that
Sony rumor it's a little bit of that
first game to start the holiday and it's
also I think remedies like
pinnacle move I think this will be again
I think I think this will be the game
and I'll give it to attic here I think
this will be the game that play that
remedy is remember for I think it'll
trump quantum break all right let's get
addict in attic dog the chat has been
weightless we we keep hearing perfect
storm perfect storm this you know what I
would consider control is a like on a
storm level it's that rain that you can
still work in that you're not getting
soaked I don't know a lot to say about
control we've been talking let's get it
AG you played this game if you you've
you close to beat me did you finish it
when I beat this game let's get it well
look the is this game horrible no but it
is not what people were making this game
out to be or acting like this game is
you know what I love hearing is
sovereigns attitude love sovereign to
death but he was like you know you you
know it's just one of those games you
have to read stuff people keep making
fun of you I might look I shouldn't have
to say people this isn't solving Kesava
doesn't care about destiny the same
people that are attacking me because I
said I don't want to read 15 page
documents to understand what's going on
or the same people were there a saint
you know what you we should have to read
stuff to know what's going on in the
Destiny world well just like look at the
end of the day you do you I do me right
but this game you okay let me just tell
you the first three in there yeah the
first three minutes you walk into
something it doesn't narrate anything
whatsoever you go to a dead body and
pick up a first officer says oh it's the
murder whatever you want to pick up the
murder weapon this woman picks up the
murder was a bad game no I think that
the stories okay was just totally so a
great break let me break you up your
issue is that it's what it's like a
grimoire situation where cuz I didn't
play the game pickup game okay like I
was inviting you pretty much get the
foundation of the story but in order to
fill the rooms if all the furniture II
need to read everything right well I
commands going actually says no the
difference with destinies we shouldn't
have to restore it on an entirely
different website to know what's going
right that that he's kind of right in
command makes a good point there it's
not a matter
I understand I had it with me I want
occurring to you know grimoires and okay
there is a difference it sounded
completely different website acting like
everyone that shed will have access to a
fob we going in like what I want to
bring out is an example that I like
games having this much text this much
dialogue people keep making fun to be
over Final Fantasy I'm like Final
Fantasy was cooking place like 15 years
ago
alright so obviously there's a lot of
dialogue in it for example see 15 14 13
12 11 and 10 are all voiced is this a
bad game no it's fantastic gameplay but
I'd have to give that story like a 6 out
of 10 and people like people like common
oh look let me give you an example of a
good game that I that I played that I
really and I've said this a couple times
right dead space okay that space you are
Isaac you do this entire game to the
narrative of fighting where your
girlfriend is but it you know if you
want to find out what happened when that
happened with your girlfriend there is
text and dialogue all over the map all
over the ship explaining to you what
happened and why everything is what it
is but they never wanna make you Oh what
it is I'm gonna spleen why because I
want you to have this same energy you
know how you do run down the black to
get that energy like ah next block I
want you to have the same energy well
we're on the next block and I think you
lost a little blood she explained
stories so I'm playing destiny in the
middle and I'm out of Hick's me up party
chat I'll drop a party chat and his him
and kids smoke him and kids move is at
different junctions in the game okay
both of them at different junctures in
the game we know attic is Earl along
that time he was okay yeah but I need a
beat the game before to get from the
mountains
overrated continue King yeah see now I
know that he was gonna beat it before
him because I'm pretty sure he threw his
control in the garbage because he was
explaining how trash the game was and
what's funny is I was like kid tell me
the story
this may could not help you know they
can see the story and then it was
arguing about the control in control
mm-hmm now Adi on the other side was
like yes hi garbage this is the control
is wack I mean he said but one thing I
do say when you're fighting a boss
you're able to rip stuff off the wall if
you run out of bullets or whatever he
was saying because I haven't played it
and he said you can beat them with your
powers he said and I haven't seen that
done in any other game and that was very
unique to that engine how they
cultivated it from the beginning all the
way he was blow vaiting on how the
engine itself was a fine piece of tech
the game that it was wrapped around was
trashed right now I'm saying that you
have to if you won't give it to him give
him to me give him that for that they
deserve because when I was listening I
did I said it was great gameplay just a
horrible story no I didn't say that all
right so so what would you what would
you give him one on one to ten they got
hit let's say and you hear from the Lord
of reviews throwing stuff that's awesome
and you know we can we can disagree all
right that's cool if you like this story
it's like I said and you know we'll give
you a clipper to the review I said I
said that if you like your gang like
control and you like fantastic gameplay
but you have to read everything in the
game we'll watch the most of the
cutscenes over and over again then this
game might be for you but it's not like
it wasn't a bad game I just felt like
the narrative wasn't all good
they didn't do it once what's funny is
any other game if there's no character
development in a game people were raging
but for some reason it's okay in control
see this is this is what I'm talking
about this is my point attention with
you with this game you have said a whole
bunch of wack stuff about it you say
it's okay the gameplay carries this
whole gang gameplay is so good narrative
a bit the gameplay is very rewarding and
I think that the one thing is is we're
addicts complaint is the reading there's
enough games now where the Sheik comes
up a lot of Resident Evil games are like
that where there's any better rewrite
nine times out of ten tells you about a
story that's already took place it's not
telling you the narrative that you're
doing but that's fine because he had a
review and he basically said that he
felt the items in the game Loki spoiled
too much if you go through the
collectibles like it'll really tell you
about the story aliyul he's right I mean
I've actually taken the time to read
about 8590 percent some of them you
could tell it's just fluff like it's
just a memo or something to move on from
that but I mean a lot of them I've
actually taking the time to read it it's
intriguing I think the real negative
though I see I have to disagree with
addict in one one one category the
reading is not the - cuz it's sam lake
anybody that follow sam lake on twitter
knows when he's not the belches he even
remained it's right wait a minute though
you can't you can't go to Pizza Hut and
complain they don't got steaks this man
writes books you know that's what he
does he's an author that's what he does
if you follow my Twitter he's always
writing books novels so screenplays so
this is what he likes and deserves to be
in a straitjacket just like well that's
a whole nother episode I always lick I
think if you want to you want to be hard
on the game where I'm where I'm gonna
come down a little bit on it is that map
but I think of somebody in the chat yeah
a map is trash you know if you don't
like the game you guys remember when
we're all young we played a game memory
cards out you to flip them over in
matches you're not good at that game
get ready for some real frustration in
this one because that map is trash you
with your memory if you want to go to
the to the mini-map because you could
bring up the mat like cool you could do
that but you're
the game performance is gonna tank just
even going into the menu when you come
out if you're in any kind of day like
any kind of battle at all probably gonna
get killed because you can't see them
because they're skipping around the map
I mean but but we're we're addict is
also corrected I will back them up on is
it listen it is the gameplay and
sometimes sometimes we have to take left
take a minute to realize that there are
certain games with a story engulfs you
certain games where the game played us
and for me personally this is hitting or
scratching an itch if you will that I
haven't gotten in a long time because
there is something different about the
game and you listen a lot of people will
sit here on this show on my show on
money shows and they'll praise games
like Bayonetta now personally I think
Bayonetta story
please allow me ping without any
royalties I can take that story I throw
it in the bush right that night this
story is nothing to me it's not what you
put the gameplay and Bayonetta is what
keeps you there so this is a new style
this is a whole new style type of play
that I think remedies got something I
think you see a lot of people start to
rip from it and the last time I just
said this this morning I just said this
this morning hasn't do it addict of the
show I said that this game is the first
game to break out a different mechanic
then I've seen since the throwable acts
in God of War it's that change the way I
played in this game changes how I think
about linear movement moving forward
it's outstanding and that's where I
think it's worth the try it's funny you
said I get that lira is how I felt about
extra change with the cable it's but
it's funny hearing from the control now
you making me excited to actually try it
especially when you get to like the into
closer to the end of the game where you
have like the majority of the abilities
if not all the abilities like it's so
satisfying to like there's like 10 or 15
and we shooting at you you pick up a
satellite and just kill them all you
literally listen you are neo at the
beginning of matrix - oh that's why oh
when they show up they show up in a
meeting and he's just like oh these must
be new you know and he just could beat
your ass like I mean like this is what
I'm talking about it's if that's that's
and what addict just said I'm not even
that far yeah I've got half the powers
he's got and I'm telling you right now
it's you
it's hashtag fun where it was
complicated but then you got to the
point it was like yo like you when you
came across a bunch of enemies you were
low-key a little scared you're like man
they about the burly on I felt like that
yeah but then when you get close close
to the end of the game you come across
that review on this is all you brought
literally like exactly you feel like neo
when you're literally in slow motion
turn sideways and you're beating a dude
completely with your left hand like
that's how I'm not right so you go and
that's and that is a great quality to
any game where what a dick just said is
true when you're in the beginning and
you feel helpless you feel like you
can't compete and then you play the game
then the game rewards you for continuing
with it and it gives you powers beyond
your actual belief and then you crush
the game no no let me just get all my
point in before because we got to move I
know we got to get much out in um just
real quick I mean just about the the
remedy acquisition I want to comment on
it you know I mean obviously I think it
would be a good fit we hear you know the
tea leaves the rumors to tweet things
like that it seems like there's
definitely something possibly brewing
there and if you know of remedy you know
goes to Sony I think it would be another
strong move and I'm saying we obviously
see in the insomniac joint you know we
thought you know that was pretty strong
and then um I think right now we talked
about it last hour P like content is
king placed at you to me if they do this
would again show that they're trying to
re-establish control for next
generations what I see myself doing with
the studios and all that and like I said
man you know Mike's grabbing up all the
studios with a total kick last week man
contest kick it is cold in the winter
this is cuffing season baby you've got
who's got a comfort of students you got
a woo your boo cuz you don't know what's
gonna happen so if anybody all you
Studios out here that simple
yo and Phil might be a remedy I kind of
low-key felt like this is a bigger
purchase and insomnia crow sorry so do
you know what time it is man war of the
studios if you're single you ain't
linked up for the winter it's cold out
here
sodium Microsoft my slider it's not even
a single man like Mike
I blew up in your wife's d-ends you
might want to lock her go forward it's
not console wars you said it just now
kognito its content wars that's what it
is it's about locking down that content
where you can't play it anywhere unless
you buy my box or service bro
studio cuffing season you heard it from
cog here first tell you man I'm a Sony
I'm a Microsoft dude you gotta do baby
the game listen I don't I don't I don't
think that it's a great idea for them to
purchase remedy um I don't think it's a
great idea I think it's a good idea oh
do they do the same things that other
studios do yeah I just don't see where
they fit in in a time I made is a gap
where they can put a game in to Coraline
with other companies that you have and
they have acquired but I'll say this
Microsoft caught up to sony Sony already
had 15 studio Ryan facts you know
Microsoft everybody's making a big deal
because Microsoft is actually trying to
compete now so let's call a spade a
spade so when I when I'm telling you
guys that you know everybody must have
that same energy so Sony put in the work
I saw with Sony first oh man I saw when
Sony was not that company and it grew to
that company they painted I call them
accident champions because a lot of way
to get to where they're at
now the disrespectful for them continued
company to take advantage of the the
stuff that presented to them yeah I
don't care who messes up but now they
have to take advantage of their
opportunities and do that at all costs
right now them acquiring another studio
is strengthening their control over the
marketplace
Microsoft purchasing Studios is
strengthening their huge weakness we got
Tyler the burger fries and a shake yes
exactly I don't I didn't think I thought
they soured their bed when they put out
quantum break because of this all the
stuff that went wrong there they could
have been purchased by Microsoft I
always thought there was a Microsoft
studio anyway but they apparently aren't
and they might be purchased by Sony is
it a good at position yes a great
acquisition would have been from
Microsoft I think they fit better there
right hey
more more more more power to LP pole
with the earlier review of previews of
gears 5 sounded extremely positive was
the gaming community wrong for having
initial concerns regarding with lack of
campaign shown at e3 for Gears 5 the
color choices are a yes fear-mongering
at its finest late into the game is
released
B no no campaign shown at e3 was still a
huge mistake or C I don't care it's a
lie can start smoking again engaged
please hit the IO people when it goes up
Lord mooch in the building the return
was outstanding got the blood boiling
the passion popping crossfire felt a
little bit on IO fever is good -
together what you got going on brother
wicked defined people find you well
first let me just say thank you to all
the Lords here I appreciate being back
on the show means a lot to come on the
show it really does because like I said
open amazing gaming dialogue is what
makes this community that much stronger
it makes us unified we've got one solid
thing in common and we got to keep
preaching that I want to say thank you
so much to ping addict Cognito and shout
out to sovereign he wasn't here but
sovereigns one of the first people I
reached out to on the iron Lords right
so me and Saab we hooked it up a minute
ago and shout out to him and it's a true
gamer and an awesome awesome man yes
shout out to Eric J who's got to deal
with the nonsense of that hurricane
hopefully it evades not only him rap I
will do a clown but if we're gonna go
down that list scrap this clown clown
lady Fox fire oh my god I think the list
keeps going on
yo police community here what Moochie
saying please hit these people yes man
make sure they're okay we burglary
storms going on we got to make sure on
gaming brethren are okay continue yes
please do actually even shout out to Jay
the Matrix gamer lots of these guys that
are out there that are they have to deal
with this and I've been talking to him
all week and my god the preparation the
preparation they have to go through I'm
talking about water gasoline food prep
boarding up the house all of that that's
all I gotta be honest with you something
that I couldn't fathom I mean we shovel
a lot up here in New York right we got
the cold and people kind of poke fun but
we don't have to worry about the
situation that they do down there so
heart goes out and I want to say prayers
are out to all those people in the south
right there that have to deal with this
but again real quick you want to say
thank you again
it's the MOOC 78 on YouTube it's
twitch.tv the Move 78 I try to keep it
unified I used to find the route right
it's at mooch 1 9 7 8 on Twitter hit me
up definitely follow and thank you again
to the iron Lord podcast because you
guys do a phenomenal job and you do a
job that no other show does and that is
bring people together okay so keep doing
what you do Cognito please and I would
be honored to return to the show I
already know you coming back man yeah
I'm so glad and I really means a lot to
hear that from you because again that's
been one of my King will tell you like
that's been one of our driving force yes
we don't care what side of the fence
you're on we don't care religion
background sexuality right it does not
matter if you pick up one of these you
are my brother
so we gonna rock together you don't say
so um yeah man that's what it's about
it's all about that unity all that good
stuff real quick I've got to pay the
bills surprisingly me Midway seven loss
over the father supercharged Sony
acquiring third-party studio
developments could Sony be typecasting
themselves good to hear on ILP mooch no
doubt your own sayings with that but
they like the single-player experience
you and I'm saying but um yeah man the
chat was live thank you for everybody
let's get up again Lord Eric Jackson for
coming in salute you know I'm saying and
um also we gotta get solved back
hopefully next week hopefully he's okay
he's been under the gun but Lord King
where can I find people finds what you
got going on sir ok well this week going
up you have oh boy first of all let me
say thank you much for coming to mooch
admire King mooch is on my
we game together alright so a lot of
people do this fraud stuff where they
don't even know they gets to come on and
they're not really following these dudes
and then essa no we actually build a
rapport with people and actually like
the people that we talk about that's
everybody you understand there's no no
funniness stuff here you know mooch is a
real do mooch is a real a gamer
all right trying to get moves the III
though anyway next year I swear I swear
on it
I will do we do there we go deal so
listen this week on king of the statues
I know y'all see God Emperor doing don't
go play yourself my review of this
statue from Zion art you did get your
behind over and stop playing because I'm
gonna tell you right now first of all
that's a custom statute is only in the
world alright there's only five of that
color alright so I'm one of the few that
have that and I'm pretty relieved and
happy that I do have that this week I
have some important stuff coming up as
far as king of the statues go we also
have combat talk with the king coming up
with girls Shawn Porter fighting for
that title for the welterweight
championship but I'm going to go into
the breakage of the statues guys and um
in the next video to this guy's are was
pissed off but I'm going to give you a
lot of my sources on how I do things
as you know statues in the box right
there ready to go um these things happen
and I'm talking with my brother Ainsley
on how to things to prevent everything's
in the future we will have a great talk
on King the statue is coming up this
week and I do want you guys if you play
destiny if you talk any type of ludus
shooter stuff make sure you go through
the last word with cognate run through
because these dudes it's putting a high
quality content
please don't see these guys thank you
brother man keeping alive man and arm
yes King salute make sure you get over
the king of statues Lords of gaming that
neck gives you more detailed information
as well as YouTube channel as well hit
that up and of course like like King
said my brother Lord Ibanez we do every
Friday 9:00 a.m.
Eastern we get the YouTube up later on
or the afternoon if you want that
destiny want that do the shooter
discussion we had great topic to talk
about shadow key we had Paul tasks you
know we got some big guests lined up and
they starting to pick up steam I see the
support thank you guys so much
you already know arm anything else I got
is it King do you got anything addict I
know had to go but everybody please
enjoy your sunday mooch win that fantasy
league for me thank you
everybody enjoy your Sunday and have a
go um up